well an officer involved shooting leaves
one person dead happened on the east
side of the valley good afternoon to you
on this Friday thanks for joining us at
four I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Sasha
Loftus it happened this morning near
Charleston and lamb that's where we find
Joshua piguero
he joins us live with the latest from
Metro Police Joshua
when we arrived on scene we're actually
quite closer to the crime scene I'm a
step out of the way here so you can get
a good look this is on Calusa Circle and
there were police and several crime
scene tape surrounding a vehicle Metro
Police say this started with the road
rage incident at around 11 this morning
a person pulled out a gun at another
driver police found that person who was
said to have the gun the driver LED them
on a chase ending near Colusa Circle in
Sacramento Drive officers then fired
into the vehicle killing the driver but
didn't say whether that person
threatened police or showed a weapon a
witness I spoke to when we first arrived
said police shot a woman
my mom said she saw them shoot the lady
in the red car like the shots were at
her
now police have not released to us if it
is a man or a woman no one else was hurt
in this shooting there was still a lot
of police as you can see behind me at
this particular location uh there's also
a crime scene tape and we don't know
when this investigation will end
reporting live near Charleston and lamb
Joshua progero eight news now Joshua
thank you for that now Metro Police do
wear body cameras we should expect to
get that video within the next 72 hours
and names of the officers that
information will come in over the
weekend